journal ce sera peut-être le fait
diplomatique majeur de cette année 89 la
ruée de milliers d'Allemands de l'Est
qui s'en vont vers l'ouest depuis la
construction du mur de Berlin
c'est-à-dire au début des années 50 les
Allemands de l'Est étaient condamnés à
rester de l'autre côté du rideau de fer
B rideau de fer on l'a vu s entrreouvert
cette année entre l'Autriche et la
Hongrie et des milliers de réfugiés
d'Allemagne de l'Est s'y engouffre il se
pourrait d'ailleurs qu'un accord
intervienne entre les deux Allemagnes
sur le départ d'autres milliers de
pour l'instant les ceux qui s'en vont
passent dans la semiclandestinité
l'équipe d'Antenne 2 avec Dominique
derda s'est rendu des deux côtés de
cette frontière
reportage un mirador tous les 200 m puis
un vaste Nans land des patrouilles
permanentes la frontière vue de Hongrie
semble infranchissable pourtant tous les
jours des dizaines d'Allemands de l'Est
passent en Autriche à cet
endroit le parking de Ferte racos c'est
ici que se retrouent fugitifs et
passeurs passeurs bénévoles et passeurs
professionnels qui demandent parfois
jusqu'à 3500 francs par personne pour
leur indiquer l'itinéraire le plus sûr à
travers les mailles du rideau de
fer la frontière n'est qu'à 1
km Johan a 38 ans il attend le moment
propice pour tenter de passer à
l'Ouest voici ma voiture que je vais
être obligé de laisser ici tout ce que
j'emporte avec moi c'est ce
sac et que contient-il ce sac une paire
de chaussur un pantalon une chemise
quelques affaires
personnelles comment comptez-vous faire
pour passer la
frontière les gens disent qu'en une
heure à pied on peut traverser les
champs et la forêt et Seiler à travers
les
Barbel pas
peur bien sûr que j'ai peur mais j'ai
tout laissé derrière moi alors il est
trop tard pour renoncer
comme Johann les fugitifs estalem ont
tout abandonné derrière eux pour
n'emporter que
l'essentiel au grand bonheur des
Hongrois des environs qui trouvent ainsi
du matériel de camping et des pièces
détaché à
profusion car ici aussi comme en
Allemagne de l'Est c'est la
pénurie les G du village ont tout
récupéré les Allemands de l'Est ont
laissé et où sont-ils ces Allemands
partis vers la frontière
là-bas 5h du matin côté autrichien
passeurs et membres de la Croix-Rouge
attendent les réfugiés aux principaux
points de
passage attention frontière d'État le
rideau de fer le voici je suis ici en
Hongrie et devant moi un énorme trou
c'est par ici que se sont enfuis des
centaines d'Allemands de l'Est en
direction de l'Autriche je traverse le
de fer me voici en Autriche le premier
village est à quelques kilomètres c'est
là c'est là qu'attendent les gens de la
Croix-Rouge autrichienne c'est là qu'ils
attendent ces réfugiés allemand pour les
conduire ensuite en Allemagne de
l'Ouest ce matin ce sont des Roumains
qui ont pris la clé des champs le chemin
qui mène à l'Autriche commence à être
connu dans tout le bloc de l'Est 2 he à
peine après l'avoir quitté en Hongrie
nous retrouvons Johan en Autriche il est
passé sans
encombre ila pas plus de ça été un jeu
d'enfant à travers les champs les vignes
la forêt et le
barbelé pas renr patrouille
hongroise de gardes ils étaient très
gentil l'un m'a même fait un clin d'œil
et il m'a laissé
passer Johan est aujourd'hui en
Allemagne de l'Ouest il a retrouvé son
fils et sa
fiancée